[Music]
are men more disturbed when they get
kicked to the curb is it time to lose
the notion that heartbroken men don't
show emotion a new british study claims
that men experience more emotional pain
and heartache than women after a breakup
or as the brits like to call it bobby in
your oddsy barge and god you should be
right chuffed you blimey wanker
sounded british
researchers used an anonymous online
forum the only kind i use
to study 200 000 postings about couples
relationship issues the number one
problem when the guy isn't named greg
the second something called
communication but the key finding was
men were more likely to open up about
the pain of ending a relationship than
women using words like regret and cry
and heartbroken well one way to get over
it watching the new british dating show
the love trap or as i like to call it
bangers and mash
david
who do you think
is a love trap
[Applause]
if it only were that easy right
so i guess we figured out what they put
in blood pudding
that's a british delicacy
frankly this whole study didn't account
though for what happens when two brohims
break up how's that work
tanner horrible news
i was only able to score two tickets to
leopard on saturday and i'm taking kyle
but logan i thought we were dudes bro we
are bros dude but he's got a 2017
wrangler sahara we can take the top off
and blast tunes and his brothers the
mater d p f changs
dude but you're like the god of my seas
brosiden
hold on there's a phone call it's kyle
he can't make it
will you go with me
pour some sugar on me bro namath let's
do this
that was beautiful
i teared up jamie
uh you seem like an emotional guy you've
had you you obviously uh have had
relationships do you have children yeah
yeah i have yeah um i wish i had that
love trap thing for when i had gotten
divorced
it would've just been so much easier
because after we did it she said a bunch
of stuff
like i wouldn't have been able to hear
it if she was down
that thing
hey by the way
some relationships aren't meant to last
and it's okay right you know like when i
got divorced i think it was one of those
okay here's a way to know if you should
get divorced uh when people start
telling you negative things about
divorce and none of it sounds that bad
to you
you know what i mean like my friend goes
dude you can't get divorced man you're
gonna have to move out of your house and
get your own place i'm like when is the
soonest we could do something
yeah but dude you're only able to see
your kids on the weekends when is the
soonest weekend
i don't want to take these kids to
school
but i actually thought there was
something wrong with me at one point not
wrong with me but i'm not like you're
typical i live in alaska a lot of manly
men and that's not me at all i went to
the doctor not i'm not joking at all and
i go could you test something like
testosterone or i feel like things hit
me harder i cry in the middle of a
greeting card sometimes like it's very
tough and he goes yeah we can do some
tasks he doesn't test he comes back and
he goes uh hey we did your testosterone
and we test himself i'm glad you came in
it turns out you are what's called a
huge wussy
and i go that's ridiculous there's no
way that's an actual diagnosis
and he goes okay you got me it's not an
actual diagnosis but i knew i could call
you that
and you wouldn't do anything
[Laughter]
based on the testing
[Applause]
so good all right cat what do you make
of this you're a girl sure am
[Laughter]
i find it devastating really yeah
because i thought the reason that guys
would get so upset
and want to get back together after we
broke up was because i was so special
apparently not no
uh poor thing it's like they all know
over there yeah they do know everybody
knows guy
uh what do you make of this
you know it's weird because let's face
it you're gay chadwick's gay
i know i should
i hope your parents aren't watching
so what happens there i mean you're both
emotional then according to this
research
yes greg well
[Laughter]
what's most difficult and the most
painful breakups for me have been ones
that are secret relationships and you
can't really confide in anyone about
your sadness right so you can't call up
a parent and say
the person i've been seeing it was going
great and then he had a show at five but
then he got another show
at 11 and now he just ghosted me you
can't say those things
[Applause]
i am so glad both my parents have passed
away
if they saw this guy might be ruined
[Laughter]
you're pretty good tonight i gotta tell
you chadwick yes sir what are your
thoughts
you know
[Laughter]
getting brutalized i think we see
breakups it's really hard um really hard
on the liver yes really hard on the
wallet
uh lots of trips to the free clinic
i think i think men just behave
differently in breakups and uh you just
have to screw everyone and drink
everything and that's how you kind of
you got to get it out you got to get it
out i have seen women doing that a lot
when they're broken up that's true but
then you get two gay guys breaking up
and then by in like a month they've
screwed all of new york city between
them
because it's just got to get that pain
out you got to screw the paint out
there you go there's a slogan for mayor
all right
up next he'll edit a classic masterpiece
to satisfy the pc police
most bladder leak pads were similar hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else